it's easy it's easier to
be more vocal about stuff and be able to
express your opinion when you've had
that opportunity to do it your whole
life and you've been in situations where
you've been able to express yourself and
not have certain repercussions happen to
you and it's like it's hard to
start doing that or try to do that when
it's been something that you haven't
been able to do our society
really says you shouldn't you shouldn't
do
no i mean we didn't like grow up like
that yeah and that's why i think the
older generation they didn't grow up
with social media
so they're like why don't you just say
your opinions yeah we're like i've seen
every influencer get cancelled since
2010
for saying the wrong thing like cancel
culture is so big it's like what is the
wrong thing is the wrong thing something
that you don't agree with so that makes
it wrong
and so all these other people that agree
with me are wrong as well i should this
is what i've noticed actually
whenever i see a clip and i get kind of
like offended by it
it's because the shoe fits a little bit
yeah
and what i've noticed is that the more
like like the angrier someone gets it's
because the shoe fits mm-hmm
and
yeah that's that's what i've i've
noticed like there is some cases where
cancel culture hack has has been good
because it's like pedophiles i'll give
them we can cancel pedophiles um one
with
the
case that happened in the summer um some
guy that was gonna be like a record
label guy he his girlfriend like posted
videos of her him abusing her and um he
was about to like get a big record label
deal and she posted it like just before
he was about to do that and like there
was videos of her like screaming and
crying and everyone's like oh do you
think do you think that's okay to cancel
him without going to court i feel like
because because you have no idea if she
was hitting hitting him first a lot of
people did like because it's like the
timing was a bit like
yeah yeah yeah the time's a bit crazy
but then at the same time if it is true
that he what like if he's gone to court
and he actually was like beating her and
stuff it's like
he doesn't well who i might say he
doesn't deserve what he's worked hard
for but i just feel like
that's the consequences of the actions
that you've done well i think it's i
think it's cool like to cancel someone
if they're found guilty but a lot of
times like the media becomes public
opinion yeah and it's like the court
the court of public opinion isn't always
correct
and the media can
as well
what sometimes that's the court of law
as well no that's true
whatever the court thinks is true if
it's truth but but the problem is in the
us it's like it's pretty hard to convict
someone of something like it's like
because the u.s
it's
it's innocent no no you are okay
no you're right that's true there's like
money like someone gets a good lawyer
they can get out of something but like
like i i've like gone to i've like
pressed charges again it's harder than
you think
i'll say something from back in the day
a person's name and i was like let me
not say that
um
so i don't know i just think like it's
easier like to post a video and paint
someone as something than it is to
convict someone yeah it's never it's
never going to be perfect right and
you never know how true and i'm not i'm
not
discrediting the situation but we often
we
when it comes to
women
there's like a
well like what happened and i don't know
if that would be vice versa like if it
was if she was going into um
a big record
label and had like a contract or
whatever and she was about to blow up
and he posted a video uh
would we question like well like why why
now
does that make sense i think
like we have believe all women
like you i'm like i don't understand
cause there's some crazy ass [ __ ]
yeah that will purposely that will
purposely and i'm not i'm not saying
that that was her yeah
they would purposely put themselves in
certain positions to ruin
someone's
complete life like um there was um
a boy years ago he
was supposed to be a top prospect for a
college no it was either for a college
or to go pro
and this
girl wasn't the one that we talked about
that one time but this girl
said that um
she he like
i don't know what the word is that woman
rape grape very good grapefruit and his
dreams were shattered and then years
later it comes to find out that it
wasn't even him or the situation didn't
even happen and it's like
how do we how do we get to that
what wouldn't why why do we just believe
hearsay she's
like
why and that's but that's even like what
we do with videos because you have no
idea what happened before like she could
have hit him over the head with a chair
before the video and then he freaked out
yeah
personally
if i was a man if someone hit me over
the child i don't care who you are i'm
knocking you i'm rocking you across the
face
but i think like i don't know we i think
women and men have this like innate
instinct to like protect women a little
bit yeah yeah because even when i post
[ __ ] on tick-tock if i'm going in on
like a girl like like they'll even if
she's wrong
and i think again i feel it too because
sometimes when i'm like
i'm going at someone it's like really
hard for me because i'm like i'm sorry
yeah
and they could be wrong i like apologize
to people after like i'm like i'm sorry
it's just part of the show
i meant what i said but i'm sorry it's
hard it's hard as
as hard as women that's why when we were
um
i can't remember his name he was here
that one time i won't know it oh you you
know his name um the guy next was he
sitting next to purple sarah yeah
yeah like he was here he was asking if
we tell our friends like you look fat or
like nah you don't look good in that
it's like we
we
don't say it like you see it like that
yeah
there's a situation
um that some of my friends were telling
me about that happened and one of our
friends
she she didn't smell too good and i
don't even know if they said anything to
her and it was just like oh y'all just
gonna let her walk around smelling like
that and i'm like did anybody say
anything and it's just hard because it's
like
when something's wrong
we want to
not hurt somebody by not telling them
but you not saying something is just as
wrong
i think women like naturally we want to
say what makes people feel good whether
than what is like true yeah
and i i think like
i'm actually guilty of doing that so
many times yeah it's like sugarcoat
everything yeah like i don't need to but
i do sugarcoat a lot of things yeah no i
do that's like why um i mean that's why
people watch me it's because they're not
used to and i think i say it most of the
time pretty nice
and like not even like you should see
some of the other podcasts that do
similar like they are not they're like
stop wifi
when i'm like look at these studies i
mean if you like
yeah i i understand do but it's like
and i feel like men don't understand
that's what i'm saying because men can
just
do it because they've that's
that's how it's been for them they can't
do it and it not come off
a certain way unless they
say it a certain way we could be like oh
my gosh like wow
amani i just want to let you know
something like this is this this and i
could say with the sweetest voice and it
could offend it could offend her just
because i can't i said something bad
about her but unless like we think of
each other as enemies sometimes as well
women like you could be you could be
saying it in the nicest way but in my
head i'm like this girl does not like me
do you know what i mean yeah yeah
instantly like was like because it's a
woman saying it to me um
like she doesn't like me yeah like she
thinks something do you know i mean yep
well and i think like i think that's
women's superpower right like i think
like being like more emotional and
empathetic like that's our superpower i
just think we've gotten to a place in
society where it's too far
like i think being able to say something
in a kind way to someone that's not a
negative thing
it's just negative when we can't
like express when we're letting men in
the women's division because we want to
be nice
and they're beating our ass
now now that we come full circle yes
96 oh we got to over 100 live viewers
guys this is the